eine justizministerin die beim begriff
diktatur ins schleudern kommt und ganze
passagen aus einem interview streichen
lässt mecklenburg-vorpommerns
justizministerin
jacqueline bernard ist unser aufreger
des tages und darüber müssen wir
sprechen wir uns im studio ist jetzt
reif schuler unser leiter des bilds
parlamentsbüros erklär uns einmal schön
gut morgen reist da genau passiert ist
also es geht einerseits um ein interview
wo sie kritische passagen zum
unrechtsstaat charakter der ddr hat
rouse streichen lassen und zwar massiv
raus streichen lassen die redaktion hat
dann nur die fragen stehen lassen und
punkte gemacht und das andere ist
einfach eine justizministerin die sich
beim thema diktatur und unrechtsstaat
davon spielt das geht einfach so nicht
sie soll den rechtsstaat repräsentieren
sie ist die chefin der rechtspflege in
mecklenburg vorpommern und das ist schon
ein ziemlicher skandal inzwischen hat
sich auch der bundesminister der justiz
marco buschmann von der fdp auf twitter
dazu geäußert das ist schon ein ziemlich
harter hund hier sehen wir jetzt unter
anderem das was stattlichen bernhard
sagt es ist unrecht geschehen in der ddr
aber jetzt zu sagen das ist ein
unrechtsstaat
dieser begriff impliziert dass ja die
lebensleistung der ostdeutschen zunichte
macht und dem würde ich mich nicht
anschließen diese passage zu streichen
lassen oder die wurde gekürzt
die ist jetzt drin selten verdruckst sie
hat auch gesagt auf die frage war die
ddr nur schnell ein nein wäre jetzt
falsch also mit anderen worten ein jahr
möchte sie aber auch nicht machen das
missverständnis hinter dieser passage
nicht die lebensleistung der ddr bürger
wird delegitimiert sondern die
ddr-führung wird delegitimiert man muss
sich einfach klarmachen
es gab in der ddr zwar gesetze aber es
gab eben auch gesetzlich
festgeschriebenes unrecht der ddr staat
seine machthaber und seine organe
beginnen systematisch unrecht wer an der
grenze menschen erschießt wenn sie weg
wollen
handelt nicht rechtsstaatlich sich darum
zu drücken das ist schon ein ziemlich
dicker hund und das andere ist man hat
inzwischen ein bisschen sorge ob in
mecklenburg vorpommern sich da ein
seltsames sed nahes beton klientel
irgendwie anreichert wir haben die
verfassungsrichterin barbara borchardt
die der antikapitalistischen linken
ihrer partei an als einer laut
bundesverfassungsschutz
linksextremistischen vereinigung und
wird dann verfassungsrichterin
mitverhandelt über den koalitionsvertrag
jetzt mit ministerpräsidentin schwesig
war torsten kopien der
ehemann gewesen ist im wachregiment
feliks dzierzynski einer struktur
einheit der stasi gedient hat jetzt so
eine sache da muss man langsam sorge
haben dass sich dort etwas im
linksextremen bereich anreichert was da
nicht hingehört die äußerungen sind das
eine das andere ist der vorgang an sich
also wir rekapitulieren nochmal da gibt
eine ministerin einer zeitung ein
interview und dann legt die zeitung
dieses interview zur abnahme zur
autorisierung dieser ministerin noch mal
vor und dann streicht sie die antworten
die sie gegeben hat wieder oder schreibt
sie noch mal wieder um das ist in der
tat ein sehr bedenklicher vorgang wenn
sie nicht zur wende schlanke 13 jahre
gewesen wäre könnte man dort eine
gewisse diktatur kontinuität
unterstellen wollen wir an dieser stelle
nicht tun autorisieren wie es in
deutschland üblich ist ist in anderen
ländern ein völliges fremdwort und ein
völliges no go in deutschland hat es die
tradition dass man sagt okay man kann
beim abschreiben so eines tonbandes
vielleicht irgendwelche setzte
zusammenziehen oder rhetorische
wendungen herausstreichen cook noch mal
drüber und bestätigen mir dass es so ist
dann hat man als interviewer den vorteil
dass der minister oder der politiker
insgesamt sich hinterher nicht
rausfinden kann habe ich so nicht gesagt
dass haben die mir den mund gelegt nein
unterschreibt das noch mal es ist nicht
dazu gedacht diese autorisierung ganze
passagen die einen politisch missliebig
sind zu entfernen oder gar um zu
schreiben und das ist hier schon massiv
wenn eine frage gestellt wurde muss man
sich dazu verhalten man kann nicht
einfach sagen diese frage gilt nicht
dass ich weg das ist klassisches
diktatur verhalten also so kann man
nicht vorgehen und das müsste eigentlich
auch die justizministerin in mecklenburg
vorpommern lernen dass also heute unser
aufreger des tages ralf schuler vielen
herzlichen dank